viewer discretion is advised
well it appears as if it's blue skies
with wonderful white clouds this
afternoon and this is safari live
panting bye
[Music]
good afternoon everyone and welcome to
safari life while sunset safari
my name is byron and on camera with me
this afternoon is of is of course craig
or batman we also have taylor in the
tent this afternoon with inner Sencha a
new camera man / woman camera woman his
innocence is filling in and helping us
out in the tent this afternoon again
which has been fun and then of course
the ladies in the final control and then
a big warm welcome to all of you it's
always nice to have all of you on safari
live with us don't forget we are
completely live so send us your
questions and your comments
hashtag safari live is how you do that
and we'll gladly answer them now I'm
approaching this Dam and this is where
Taylor managed to find young husana &
young male leopard this morning so I'm
going to see hopefully he's still around
now they were apparently tracks of a
female in this area too so wonder if
there isn't another leopard around here
it's actually been a cool afternoon so I
wouldn't be surprised if this leopard
did decide to move so we'll have to have
a good little look around here alright I
think let me have a good look I might
just walk around and see if I can find
any tracks they take to Taylor so she
can say good afternoon to you hello
everybody and welcome again as Byron
said she's Safari live and live and
interactive Safari my name is Taylor and
on camera with me today is in a sense
share and well hopefully we're going to
find all sorts of things and perhaps
we'll have a look at some clips a little
bit later too
now as you know the tensors can be quite
difficult at this time of the year
because it isn't really much in terms of
insects and things Archer it's
particularly quiet now I have got
something however to show
you on the microscopes if you'd like to
go to the microscope you're welcome to
and then we can investigate and see what
I've got
there's a piece of grass that I managed
to find outside I'm just trying to move
it around because there's all sorts of
things in here just bear with me I'm
gonna pull it out very quickly and try
and turn it around it's very windy all
of a sudden at one point I thought the
monitors we're going to blow off the
table and out into the bush there we go
now if you look very carefully in there
you'll see that there's a variety of
insects there's a piece of grass and
some it has a little spider in it now
I'm gonna try and find a spot of it
because all the things that it's eaten
this is this very little life out there
at the moment and one of them on the
right looks like a termite that are
interesting and if I change the focus
there's like a little merge of some sort
you can just see in the top middle of
your screen that quite beautiful look at
those wings but now you might be able to
spot the spider in between all that sort
of well death I suppose you could call
it you might be able to see something
moving it's a very small spider I don't
know what it is it's beautiful though
they means if I can turn it around again
it's you can see it's just moving over
there it's got beautiful hairs on it and
it's got quite a dark sort of head and
dark negs it's see if we turn it I
actually didn't even see it with my eyes
to be honest if I angle it like that
well we're gonna get a view it's very
difficult another wind no wind stop
blowing oh there we go I think we can
just gonna see it now and you just
change the focus yeah yes okay now I'm
gonna work out how to bring it closer to
the screen it's so difficult to work
with microscope there it is
hmm look at it I wonder if it's not a
very small hairy field spider Oh quite
common Archer we see them all over the
show and they're related to all web
spiders within it's its web is slightly
different because what it's actually
done it since there may be it's not even
a hairy field spider perhaps it's
something else it might be even too
difficult to try and identify because
there's quite a lot of obstructions it
might be the size of two or three
put together that's how tiny it is that
amazing and like I said it's done a
different type of a web so it hasn't
built in a normal all browned web it's
actually taken the pieces of grass and
pulled them together and then used a
very fine silk almost like a netting and
wrapped it around the grass so that's
where those lives inside the middle of
the web and that will also help protect
it it will stop em anything sort of
blowing into it so it's quite safe and
there and then it's got all this little
insects trapped on the outside and it
changed their focus a little bit oh
that's so amazing
I could honestly stare at this for ages
that is so cool I really want to try and
figure out what spider we have
underneath the microscope and I might
have to do a bit more playing around
maybe if I do some digging I'll outside
I'll be able to find some some more
spiders for you hopefully well that
that's the idea of course today but if
there's anything that you'd like to have
a chat about you're welcome to hash tags
for it I've let us know and you can help
me keep myself and you all entertained
in the tent because it's very quiet in
here unfortunately hopefully the the
ladies and final control can dig up some
footage for me of the buffalos and lions
and we can have a chat about that
because that's definitely been a hot
topic over the last few weeks there's
also a car alarm going off I think this
is a good time to get back to buyer it
and see if he's had any luck with those
late birds unfortunately not yet Taylor
we are looking like that
leopard definitely moved off as I
thought as I thought it would have these
young leopards move around a lot during
the day a lot more than we think and
especially today when it was so much
cooler so you're just going to have to
have a careful look around here
check those drainage line very carefully
because I think if anything may be moved
up into this area somewhere it's tricky
we know like even this morning with them
trying to track him they walk they was
so close to that Leopard any he didn't
even move so it's not easy to find them
if they are lying down especially when
the grass is like this this color and
very well camouflaged will never look
around and see maybe maybe we get lucky
I'm sure there are still around here
somewhere I say they if that's assuming
these two leopards in this area
check the termite mounds check some of
the trees maybe we're lucky we're gonna
be great to see a leopard in a tree I
haven't seen a leopard up in a tree for
quite some time
I hope you having a great weekend
everybody or the end to a good weekend
and just a reminder and it's going to be
a time change and it is from the first
of August so from the first of August
there is a time change with our Sun Rise
Safari we are going to be half an hour
earlier so half an hour earlier for a
sunrise Safari
so we are going to be live from 6
o'clock on so that 6 o'clock was 6 a.m.
Central African time sorry Craig
I feel like rusty shocks are no longer
exist in existence so that's from the
1st of August we still trying to work
out we will let you know if we're going
to be changing the sunset Safari the
times for the sunset Safari but we will
let you know but from the 1st of August
time change for the sunrise Safari at so
half an hour earlier come on there's got
to be a leopard on these termite mounds
here somewhere
would you check this little pen very
carefully nice cover
and it's a perfect spot for leopards to
hide
young leopards especially but I have no
idea which direction they would have
gone or he would have gone
you see anything it Craig I can see some
Franklin moving through the grass but no
sign of a leopard just yet
lovely cool afternoon so is this Leopard
could also potentially be lying out a
little bit more in the open maybe not
necessarily well-hidden but you never
know so I'm gonna be doing a few loops
around ya and just see if we can find
the slippered times like this I really
wish I had my friend
Judas then I used to work with such a
great tracker
a lot of experience and he just had a
sixth sense when it came to finding
finding leopards and tracking leopards
I have no doubt if it if he was with me
now we probably would have had the leper
already
now jamesy as you were saying it would
have been nice to see her sana this
afternoon and hopefully was it would be
where he was left this morning that's
what I was hoping for James but he
definitely moved away from there so I
don't know which direction he went
trying to have a careful look any sons
any tracks anything like that but I do
think he's somewhere in that area I
don't think he would have moved too far
but you never know with these young
lipids especially this young male
you know he's independent now he's
moving around a lot more but but still
exploring the area not not really quite
sure what to do is still very young is
only about a year and a half almost a
year and a half old
so still young usually this is the time
that that females would probably leave
their cubs because once they get to a
year and a half old that's usually the
average age for leopards to reach
independence but in the case of this
young male and young female whose son
and Shawn Gilley and if their mother
left him a lot earlier and almost just
oh I think I was just over a year old so
it's quite young but they've done well
for themselves they've survived which is
wonderful and I mean we saw this young
male this morning we watched a clip on
it - Ellie found him wrestling or kind
of wrestling or playing tug-of-war with
a hyena over a Impala caucus so he's
clearly not really really afraid of much
there's one Impala Becky
and sometimes all it takes is just
driving very very slowly and scanning
stormy sea you asked if I can check on
the generate for us later I will indeed
stormy sea huh wonder if that Janet is
still in the tree it would be lovely to
see that little Janet again one of my
favorite little nocturnal creatures
definitely Janet speaking of nocturnal
creatures or animals that are active at
night last night I was I was lying in
bed and heard these footsteps outside
and thought it might be Batman heading
out on his nightly watch but it was at
Batman it was a Heine that it was
walking through our camp I came to see
if the dustbin was out I had to chase
the hyena off last night
I'm just trying to check very carefully
to see if I can't see any tracks around
here but nothing yet
it's interesting when the slippered was
a bit younger when this young male was
younger and the female would often leave
the femur would often leave Hassan and
shakeela or Corolla would leave them and
and they would often lie on top of
termite mounds now leopards enjoy lying
on top of termite mounds it's a little
bit more comfortable than just lying in
a tree and also gives them a nice
vantage point to have a look around and
see where or if there any animals around
or it's just a nice little spot to lie
but they haven't done it for what I
haven't seen seen him lying on a termite
mound for quite some time
I haven't seen any tracks along the road
so that just makes me think again that
that this leopard must have gone and and
walked up the drainage line possibly I
suppose it could have walked up or down
I'm car speaking about that I hi
narrating the dustpan yours is it safe
for the hyenas to eat - animal see from
the dispenser I dearly know you know
it's not a good idea for them to eat
from the dust bins but the hyenas
scavengers they eat just about anything
I've seen a hyena
- through a steel Kittel that you those
stainless steel kettle you put them on
on the fire when you go camping I've
seen a hyena bite through half of that
incredibly powerful jaws and they'll eat
just about anything but but no
technically not so that's how we drop
with the dustpan in the in the kitchen
during the the evening just to try keep
the hyenas at bay but they don't come in
every night then Heine I haven't heard
was seen a hyena and for quite some time
but heard it last night and walk talked
in there it was
[Applause]
I really hope I get to find this leopard
for you just gonna take a little drive
down here quickly just to scare in this
area I'm not sure if it is down here or
not
so nice thick area here so it's perfect
for this leopard to hide in to keep your
eyes peeled everyone
that's why sometimes it's amazing and it
can get a bit frustrating at times you
can drive around and come around the
corner and bump into a leopard right in
front of you and then other times you
can drive to the spotty loss or the
leopard hoping that it would be there
and there'll be absolutely nothing and
then you can search for hours and not
find them so I was hoping you would have
moved into this area somewhere just off
to our left
and this substrate till the soil around
it is actually very hard this is almost
like a mud clay or clay like swell so
it's very very hard it wouldn't be easy
to see tracks on this actually hold on a
second I'll just speak to your exit
so I'm just listening to update from the
other guides quickly
good afternoon mobile stations and Byron
young Henry and and Rickson I'm just at
triage damn at the moment trying to
follow up no sign of that animal just
yet I am checking the area quite
carefully
sounds like maybe one or two people
might be interested in coming to have a
look around to see if they can see this
Leopard or find this Leopard with us all
right well Taylor's still in the tent
she's going to be there all afternoon so
we're gonna have a look around yeah
let's head back to Tyler see what she's
got planned for the afternoon exactly
got anything I apologize I'm on I'm now
sort of looked quite short don't I'm not
on the chair just down on the ground I'm
trying to reopen everything that I'd had
open unfortunately we had to do a
massive reboots just not I don't know
what happened well my feeds started
disappearing and okay well we won't be
able to do that now they must have to
close all of this yes I would really
like to talk about Lions vs. Buffalo
today at some point and just because
it's one of the things that I've
actually prepped before the tent going
into depth and hopefully looking at some
sightings that we had last year with
wool incredible and Kahuna's as they
were known at one point when we used to
see them every single day remember I
think it was a hundred days of cats then
that sounds whenever I fantastic that
was and that of course was because the
Buffalo were back and were around and
now we're waiting for them it we will
get into that hopefully if we can dig up
some some of the many thousand clips
that we do have we do have those we can
have a look at the microscope I managed
to find no that's a gate I heard a
high-pitched squeaking noise this time
it's not anyone playing sucker sure turn
sometimes voice is very loud in my ear
today so have a look at that it's a
little pod now it's from a the monkey
pod sinan you may remember yesterday
Byron had that beautiful sighting of go
away birds and also the crested barbets
they were feeding on the beans now this
one slightly rotten and looks like
something it actually started eating
away it and I'm not exactly sure what it
would be but it definitely must have had
quite a strong mandible and GPS through
that it's not big enough for it to sort
of to be damaged from a bird it's just
the time
little spots I think it was an insect of
some sort but isn't that absolutely
beautiful look at all the tiny little
hairs that are actually on that let me
see if I changed a focus up slightly
what else we can get that's really yes
let's see it's completely hollowed it
from here uttered it out now I can come
back to me and we can have an actual
look at one and just broke the the
rotted part or fern it's quite an
interesting little pod and I get quite
long and down over here now there's
quite a few Center species in in the
country then what actually supposed to
be here but we have a couple that are
alright well the birds don't seem to
mind them because they provides nice
fruit delicious things now I don't know
if you can even eat these I'm just
trying to think I've never heard of
anybody being able to eat them so we'll
have to pop it into the interweb to have
a look let's see if I can get one out it
looks very much just like a pea let's
see quite small so it's quite difficult
to sort of handle mm-hmm Oh something
not tickling my throat look at tiny that
is so that is the entire little bean
that you can see and that is what to go
away birds and the crested barbets
are actually going after you can imagine
you need to eat quite a few of those to
be able to get any sustenance I'm sure
they've got a decent nutritional value
to them so it'll be quite healthy for
the birds and for anything else that's
really feeding on them now I've got
something else we can even put under the
microscope
let me quickly change it this is quite
cool yeah should we have another look at
the microscope there we go look how cool
that is that also makes for a great
screen service there we put up the goal
of a silver cluster teeth now this is a
quarry leaf that the caterpillar has got
hold of you can see it's not any fresh
damages it actually happened quite some
time ago you can see how it dried out
it's the dead parts of the leaf are now
but it's just amazing and I think I may
change the change the height of it so we
can get a bit of you and when you should
have change of focus that is
absolutely amazing now if you look at
the size of a caterpillar and the damage
that they can do to trees is pretty
amazing don't you think and they do
create beautiful sort of patterns
something what I will do is I'll go and
son and see if I can't find a leaf that
has been attacked by a leaf miner now
they make all sorts of interesting
patterns too but they sort of seem to do
it inside the leaf they don't actually
break the outer layer of the leaf at all
so it's almost like they create little
see-through part tunnels through the
leaf itself so that'll be quite pretty
sigh laughs - go and explore and see if
I can find any of those I'm also trying
to dig out an antlion so that we can pop
it under the microscope
and hopefully have a look at the and
mine at some point but I thought that
was quite nice what else have we got
yeah we've got some bark which I'm
collecting them but I'm not going to
talk about the bark of the various trees
just yet because I'm still trying to
make a decent collection the most common
trees that are outside the chained are
silver clasp League worries and there's
some square raisins and that's really it
that's around you a couple of Bush
willow so I might have to do a bit of
exploring to go and get some marula bark
maybe some nod form bark I might have to
actually walk out onto quarantine to go
and grab those things and hopefully
we'll find some I also try and turn over
a couple of logs because it is a little
bit cooler we know that the insects
aren't necessarily too active and what
I'm hoping to find when loud and
hopefully I'll be I'm sorry I decide to
turn that down quickly before I pierce
my ear drum and hopefully I'll be able
to find a scorpion wouldn't it be nice
to have a look at a scorpion under the
microscope I think we could be lucky if
we peel back some bark and we turn over
some big logs but we're gonna go back to
Byron he's searching far and wide for
leopards surely husana couldn't have
gone too far years a sneaky cat though
it seems as though he's taking after his
father but let's go back to Byron and
Craig
we are indeed ten I hope you find some
interesting little creatures under the
bark and under those logs we have got
we've had no luck just yet but it's
still early so maybe just maybe we get
lucky
when lipids go hiding why did they do
that
spazz if it was easy and we'd lose the
the thrill of looking for these animals
again it is very tricky and to drive as
charged scan and look for tracks is very
difficult and I'm almost certain that we
miss a lot of the tracks of these
animals and I've been doing this long
enough that even even with the track on
the front of the vehicle at times we
must tracks and all it all it takes is
for track just crossing the right
doesn't necessarily mean that they
walking straight down the road it could
just be one or two tracks crossing the
road and if we don't see that we're
looking completely the wrong place so it
is difficult it's very difficult
who knows probably hiding in the
drainage line somewhere what we can also
do is maybe drive around a little bit
and come back into this area a little
later maybe we have more luck then but
for now there's absolutely no sign of
that Leopard so I don't know where he
would have gone
so little little windy this afternoon
there's a bit of a breeze you can see
some of the trees moving in the wind
let's just do one more one more loop
back and just have a look again
you never know often persistence in the
bush pays off
might I might go check that area or
check chat to chat with damn again this
afternoon we had a lot of lucky
yesterday those two hippo fighting it
was amazing really really incredible to
see and I had a question yesterday
speaking about the hippo we had a
question from Chitty chatty Meg asking
if the hippo are related to whales now I
thought that that's very bizarre what
what are the chances
but apparently apparently archeologists
believe that the whales porpoises
dolphins and hippo are all related and
that whales are distant cousins of
hippos I find that absolutely bizarre
and I mean I think if you're going that
far back everything's basically related
perhaps but I mean if you like millions
of years ago they reckoned it was a
dinosaur and it weighed about a hundred
pounds or something and it was well
liked and hit by like or something like
that I don't know it's just I mean
that's going too far back I think I
think the animals have evolved in such a
way that if you're not picking that much
to say that they related
anything can be potentially related it's
like that's basically like saying James
and I or distant cousins imagine that
[Laughter]
also badly want to see a lipid stick
netted out and surprised us
do one more check down here
see like I say potentially could have
gone anyway
rusty please don't bend the steering rod
today all know I've had seriously bad
luck with rusty in the steering rods
it's not from bad driving I promise you
that it just for some reason it's got a
weak steering rod the support that is
meant to be there isn't there so I'm so
careful not to benders neither steering
rod
come on Craig we need a spotter Leopard
it's funny it's almost like this
temperature doesn't know what to do the
afternoon it's cool and then now it's
warm again because soon as the Sun gets
away from those clouds that's warm
lovely termite mound here and some nice
trees a lot of shade perfect little spot
for a leopard actually I could always
just send Craig in on foot and wait for
something to happen I'll film Craig
now I see the vehicle tracks over here
and I'm not sure if that leopard moved
and people followed it this way or if
this is just vehicle tracks from them
searching for them this morning I don't
know I've seen it odd track sir
I'll retain you asking about carnivals
and what they feed on and if they eat
the bones of the refracting sorry I put
they're gonna Sam Franklin gave me a
front that can fly straight into the car
see on on edge yeah looking for this
meteors if the carnival's feed on the
bone or our bones of the predator of the
food that they eat ricci you know a lot
of the time they do but it's it's mostly
those it's mostly those smaller bones
not the big bones not the really really
large bones the the hyena hyena probably
feed on on the largest bones out of all
the carnivores because they've got such
powerful jaws so they definitely do feed
on just about anything was many of the
bones as possible whereas lipids will
feed on maybe the smaller rib bones some
of the other small bones and you can
often hear them crunching away when they
are feeding and hear them crunching on
the bones and it's also they do get a
lot of nutrients a lot of calcium and
phosphorus from that
he's laughing at me cake Craig's
laughing because I stole the vehicle
it's a log Greg no Craig's teasing me oh
it's the most emotion we've seen from
Craig for about three days so that's
good now we you were chatting about the
Tainter net this morning and it's we've
had a lot of help from in essentia
forming for us in the ten twelve Tyler
and I have shared the tent
responsibilities and Justin sent us a
message this morning when he woke up
bright and early at about 10 o'clock
he's on leave so he deserves it just
saying that tent seems to be a hit and
it has been fun
yeah you know what I'm getting myself
into a bit of trouble here it's quite
thick around here now you know what
everyone I've had no sign of these
leopards I don't know where they've gone
all this one leopard that was yeah I'm
not sure if they were too
[Applause]
just try to squeeze through here perhaps
there's a sim bak there's any gap
through ya idea
I definitely seem to be getting myself
deeper into trouble here and while
looking for these leopards or leopard
young Eric you asked if leopards eat
anything other than just meat well yeah
I suppose if you just mean yeah I mean
they've feed on fish we know that we've
seen them catching catfish in muddy
waters before we've seen them I've seen
leopards feeding on snakes seen leopards
feeding on Birds seen leopards feeding
on tortoises and Terrapins if you mean
do they do they snack on the odd fruit
no I've never seen a leopard eat a fruit
seeing them drink grass but much like
pits cats and in dogs
they'll eat grass if they if they was
suffering from indigestion or helps the
digestive system or will cause them to
regurgitate something so so I've seen
you know the cats do their - the big
cats do that too but a wide variety of
food for the leopards they'll feed on
just about anything
just want to listen to the radio to see
what the other guys are looking for this
afternoon
see there's some other guests out at the
moment on this afternoon Safari and they
probably watching us wondering what we
are doing in this area would be great if
we found the leopard and at least they
we had a good reason to come through
yeah but my son
like I say we don't really know which
direction he could have gone you could
have got North Creek on stuff all right
well I think what we might do is move
out of this area we'll probably try to
come back a little bit later maybe when
it gets cooler if the lipids still in
the area it'll stick its head out and
maybe move around for us we'll come down
to drink so let's head back to Taylor in
the tent while I get out of this area
well hello everybody I've been running
around outside trying to find things
we'll to talk about I don't have a fuss
occur in chief I am the fuss occur in
chief I suppose I suppose James dubbed
me with that and well now doing all the
jobs right so I've been looking outside
you just pick up some of the stuff that
I was looking for he's got to scoop it
back in my hand now goes once that's
what I'm looking for if you look at just
in the palm of my hand you'll see that
there's some very very small bits of
dung in that tiny got small they are so
I have a question for you can you guess
whose dung that is who dung it hashtag
Safari live with your guesses and then
we shall go into it you've got to be
quick though this should be an easy one
very very easy one okay let me put it
down now there's something else that I
want to have a look at what else have we
got so I'm actually going to take that
dung away because we'll get back to that
in a moment
hmm look at this no this is the type of
bracket funghi as you can see
fortunately doesn't seem to be doing too
well it's also winter so it's not
absorbing a lot of nutrients
unfortunately from its from its host but
this one is known as orange tuft and
I've actually found it around here
before it creates to grow on the Inaba
thorn should we put it under the
microscope and have a look let me see
what it actually looks like whoa that's
pretty cool look at that now you can
actually see the haze now we've looked
at it before
a lot softer than this and a lot more
pliable too oh my goodness all my dong
is rolling around the wind is blowing it
everywhere and it's actually quite toxic
this stuff and believe that a term it
can be used to enter a trance-like state
as opposed if you're trying to contact
your ancestors it would be a good spot
to trial or good stuff to try and use
that however I'm not going to be eating
much of it but it's very very pretty now
see if I can find some other type of
fungi that's out in the but there is
although they used to be at one point
quite a bit of it but I don't know where
it's all disappeared it's forgotten the
bath the things around the taint and I
also tried to turn over quite a few logs
but unfortunately no luck there so any
any guesses just you just to who who
don't surely there must be do you think
you could read them to me please Chantal
that's a bit difficult to grow over to
the document say that again
currency currency squirrel that's a good
guess very very good dude but
unfortunately no cigar and that is not
from a squirrel oh now Phil and Jeannie
animation you say a bird nope it's not
from a bird but good cases though
remember if it was from a bird you would
actually see quite a bit of white from
the the uric acid but you can see that
this lacks any white at all and it's
very small any more guesses now the good
guess Kestrel [ __ ] she say scrub here it
isn't but you've just given me something
else to go and look for Kestrel Fox
that's what I'm gonna go and find or
another great gaze from
wellif and you say Mongoose not quite
Mongoose but Mongoose is similar shape
though but Mongoose can you believe it
is actually slightly bigger than this
well I think there might be one or two
right answers and but we'll just go
ahead and I'll just tell you what it is
this is actually Decker dung can you
believe it
all of the stuff here now in that
amazing now the reason why it's not
stand walk down is because it wasn't
typically Stan walk will vary their dung
and then you'll have to sift it up from
the sand so this is from the daycare and
I thought it'd be a good opportunity to
perhaps chat about some of the smaller
antelope that normally hide away in in
the long grass but now that all the
grasses of course are dropping down to
well below knee height we're starting to
see them and have been seeing lots and
lots and lots of Jake a lots of steer
and walk art in a bar coming down to
drink him the watering holes now and you
remember because all the little pans
pretty much most of them have actually
dried up now like I say chili pans
completely dry it's just mud they're
coming down to the dams that are full
which is exciting I know it sounds
absolutely silly but you don't often get
to see those small antelope out in the
open they feel very vulnerable and this
is also the time of the year where
unfortunately they can stay and walk
feature on the menus of the animals that
Byron is looking for so lipids lipids
love to catch a deck in Steinbach and
you can imagine for someone or leopards
like Xiang ji leh and husana and even
Tambor to an extent they'd probably be a
little bit on the easier side to try and
catch those pentalobe oh my goodness I'm
feeling slightly parched I'm going to
have to have something to drink enough
to have some water to quench my thirst
now and I keep that sounds like a girl I
feel that I've got a frog with something
stuck in my throat but without further
ado you can you believe it
Byron has magically pulled and leopard
out of his sleeve
yeah we found him everyone we found him
we found him we found him move down the
opposite direction there he goes because
we're gonna view of him
he looked as if he was talking something
moving through the bush at the moment as
I said the temperature cooling down
chances of finding him more but better
and there is Roger next us I'm not sure
what he saw may have been a little day
kill with Steinbach there he is and
follow my audio we'll sit tight tails it
tight oh that well this has made my
afternoon thankfully it was Craig that
spotted him too saw his head sticking
out in front of us we came back down the
same road again you see the persistence
driving around a few more times just
paid off and luckily we've got to find
him and just in time because now he's
moving even further away from the dab
I'm just gonna move off the road
slightly there's a car behind us so I
just want to give them a view of this
leopard - we'll wait for him you might
you might decide to come out into the
road this was wait and see
very good there he is he's approaching
the road now isn't that a nice surprise
you see once we found him then he
decides to walk out in the road but
before that that's hiding in a thicket
lovely view
or what a nice surprise
wasn't that great drop follow him for a
little while and see where he goes you
see it appears as if he's if he's
hunting necessarily but leopards are
always very opportunistic so I'll have a
look around and if they flush anything
as we did while we were driving through
that drainage line we flushed a little
Steinbach so this lipid would be looking
for something like that to Steinbach or
a darker possibly Impala if he does see
any just try to move again
Paul you say this is your favorite big
cat where did your favorite big cat
Gopal and you see him there is it's
amazing how they can sometimes disappear
and move around quite quickly
our once was following a leopard and and
it was a female she was walking down the
road and we thought we'll drive around
and just wait for her basically on the
corner and try get a nice view over
walking down the road and she we'd lost
a view of her for a split second and she
disappeared we couldn't find her again
I'm sure he disappeared into the long
grass it was incredible really amazing
to see okay so that's why these animals
are so elusive but when you do see them
that is really such a lovely surprise
you can hear some rattling sticklers
alarm calling at the leopard while is
walking now we might see what they often
do I can still see him there just moving
through there what they what they often
do is when these birds alarm call at
them the leopards occasion he lifts the
tails up he's not quite doing it at the
moment the reason for that is there's a
very clear white marking under the tail
so when these birds alarm call it the
leopards when they're walking through
the bush they lift the tail up to make
themselves more visible and the reason
for that well the theory behind it is
that they showing that they're not a
threat they know no danger they're just
passing through so they're lifting their
tails up making themselves more visible
to hopefully stop those birds from alarm
calling at them because what happens is
then they draw a lot of attention to
them which they don't want but it is
interesting it often said with leopards
walking and they love details
immediately there he comes not sure if
he's seen anything again damn you say
leopards are so mysterious
yes mysterious elusive I really are
really are wonderful wonderful animals
and you see how he's constantly scanning
and checking the area JC you asked have
I ever been frightened by a leopard I
told a story the other day actually we
were tracking a big male leopard and
down the south on Wanda nosey and thus
leopard he walked around the car for
about five minutes we couldn't see where
the tracks went and as we took two steps
off the road
he basically burst out of the bushes in
front of us he was lying there the whole
time hiding and and as soon as we took
steps towards him he then gave a growl
but you didn't actually charge us he
just ran out and around to the back of
the bush again but we got
myself and my tracker that I worked with
Judas my friend he him and I both got a
fright the guests laughed at us they
thought it was quite funny yes I have
been I've got one or two frauds from
lipids before
I don't see where he's going it would be
wonderful if we saw some Impala up ahead
any small antelope could be could be
quite interesting but again just look
how well he blends in soon as he starts
walking behind these trees now you can
see him quite nasty with him because of
Craig's great camera work but for us
sitting here it's actually quite
difficult once he goes through the long
grass he disappears
oh did he see something that he seemed
just run he just had a little little dot
at something but he stopped again it
could also be little mongooses rotc once
he seen hold on I don't want to lose him
Craig I'm gonna toss squeeze through
here quickly
[Laughter]
there he goes there he goes still got
him straight aid just gonna park here
let's just see he straight ahead of us
but let's just see and scan if he has
spotted something up ahead the way but
the way darted off he he had like I said
it could have been
Mongoose it could have been Franklin's
although the Franklin's probably would
have made a noise
Bobby interesting question you asked if
the leopards fur is smooth or coarse now
Bobby I've never felt a leopards fur but
I believe that the leopards fur is
actually very soft very smooth very soft
now the other big cats lion and cheetah
are very coarse near he is very cause I
felt cheetah before and I'm just gonna
stop here again so I'm giving him a bit
of space I don't want to disturb him too
much
and so we've quite be quite far from him
now but he's still just ahead of us or
some driving off roads so that I don't
lose view of him I'm just checking out
in front of him to see if there is
anything but look look how well he
disappears in that in there grass look
at that isn't that camouflage incredible
so Bobby yeah and so I believe that the
leopards fur is quite soft
it's probably gonna come out on that
road again and maybe that's why I
stopped to look around just to see if he
if he does expose himself out into the
opening that nothing is there to
potentially see him while we wait for
his sauna to expose himself let's go to
James and hopefully he doesn't expose
himself but he's in the mara let's see
what my old friend James Henry is up to
so I'm Mari you can see the pink ling of
the sky there you can see the golden
bellies of some very fat lions indeed
and well shortly we'll show you some
vultures my name is James Henry and it's
very nice to be back out in the field
with you hello Fergus fergus's on camera
he is and we're going to be out here
probably well certainly into the
darkness I don't know exactly how many
segments we're gonna do from here but
our plan is to basically find three
things this is the sort of general
directive the one is lions
the second is wildebeest and the third
is signal with those three things we're
fairly guaranteed we hope of some action
well we've got Lions there there huh and
then well beyond them by about say 300
metres you can perhaps see a line of
what probably looked like little black
ants those are the Volta beasts but I'm
not sure that we have a great deal of
signal where those wildebeest are so I'm
not sure and zebra look at that but you
can see that the migration herds have
now come up well north of where they
have been before this year there are
many to the north of us and even with
our very favoured and gamma pride they
are now starting to come into their
territory we saw a small group there and
if this bunch don't look like they're
going to get up and do anything which
I'm seriously doubting they will because
they've certainly killed the wildebeests
just down the road and then left it I
think that we will probably head back to
the in Garmon frier territory as
darkness falls and see what happens over
there remember
you can talk to us hashtag Safari live
we're just as live as Taylor in the tent
and Bayern in the bush you see I did
that their focus mmm very nice and you
can ask us anything you like send us any
questions or comments we've had a very
pleasant weekend here we obviously did
our TV show on Friday on Saturday
morning and then this morning I came out
here found these lions and well they
don't seem to have moved more than three
inches they very nearly killed a zebra
this morning he a young foal that had
been separated from the herd somehow
pretty much walked up to what almost 30
feet beyond the second tree trunk that
you can see there and these Lions could
not have been more than 40 feet from it
and they just sort of carelessly had a
bit of a run but they didn't make any
real attempt at cunning or stalking or
anything else like that and so
unsurprisingly
they missed they were unsuccessful
they've just had to digest the five or
six meals they're probably ate last
night so it is boon time or boom time
here up in the northern triangle the
weather today well looks like a storm
coming in over the Oder Lolo escarpment
which is a little bit disturbing given
the amount of time that we began to be
out here and Bombo girl you say that
they are fat flat cats they could not be
better described there are certainly fat
they're certainly flat and well yes
there certainly cats aren't they so what
I think we'll do from here is probably
just reverse and try and get down into
that migration herd see if we have
signal there I don't think we're going
to and if we don't and we'll come back
here see what they're going to do and if
they don't do anything in the next half
an hour or so we'll head back towards
the end guard or pride just in the
distance I can hear that but I ain't
[Music]
beautiful beautiful vultures and storks
all over the place here such a good time
for them of course and I believe that
Byron is having a lovely time out in the
bush he's always wanted to be known by
the moniker little chief and so that is
why he is following the little chief
we are indeed James I'm great to have
you with us from the Mara hope you
having a lovely day up there and Sanne
has now gone and he's laid down a little
bit but again just look at that
camouflage I mean look how well he
blends in with that grass I honestly
think if you were just scanning through
here you wouldn't see metal with the
naked eye look at that very difficulty
spot this is such a nice treat
especially because he's moving around on
this morning he lay lay down and those
of you were watching this morning
sunrise Safari was on his back and
almost fast asleep resting paws up in
the air
you know at one stage was resting his
poor on the log and he was lying next to
such a lovely afternoon so I say there's
still the cool temperature there's a bit
of a breeze can hear some birds calling
in the distance a few Cape turtledoves
the the he leaves are rustling at the
moment in the the dry leaves are
wrestling in the wind
cynic you asked if I've ever seen lipids
I'm just listening home and a second
these birds are going wild I wonder if
it's because rattling says sticklers all
along I'm calling a huge group of them I
wonder if it's because of the leopard
lying down there I think so so see Nikki
asked if I've ever seen a leopard lying
in the long grass and jumping out and
attacking its prey or or ambushing its
prayer I have seen leopards Hanten stalk
and kill before not often but but I have
indeed seen it yeah others as dealers
syste killers calling listen to that
can you this
are they straight straight behind him in
that tree I mean that blue Bush so just
up to the left there we go they're all
sitting look at that rattling so
sticklers down a little bit Craig there
we go
just there we go at the bottom of the
branch all those trees now the rattling
so stickler has been called the black
member of the bird world the reason for
that is the inside of the rattling so
sticklers mouth is pitch black
and you might be able to see it a little
bit with that one chirping at the bottom
left here we go you see the bright black
mouth inside inside and and I have heard
of them being referred to as the black
member because of that the black mamba
snake obviously has that pitch black oh
there's a sugar shaker just joined looks
like a brown Crown Chakra
like one of the white brown over there
so it's come to investigate why are
these birds alarm calling it's one to
wanted to have a look that's one of my
favorite little birds as she grows but
those rattling sticklers do not give up
tenacious little birds constantly alarm
calling if there's any sign of a
predator there's a few of them there so
as I was saying that black mamba could
has a pitch-black mouth that's where it
gets the name from not because of the
color the snake itself is actually gray
in color but it's that pitch black mouth
win it or when it opens its mouth if it
feels threatened and the same with that
rattling so stickler
scenic you asked what other species of
sista killer do we have in this area
just think the red faces tickler I'm not
mistaken I think they I think like edges
of little rivers and that and that
red-faced testicular we have sitting so
stickler we get in this area to what
else do we get I mean just have a look
here quickly so we've got the rattling
the the setting so stick euler trying to
think that don't we get thee the lazy
sista killer also occurs in this area I
haven't seen one of those because all
those are the only ones that I can think
of rattling red-faced lazy and the
setting so stickler
wings snapping sista killer I've never
seen one of those though but says they
occur in the area the way links are
sticky lunch I don't think of the
whaling yar
the whaling occurs in this area a little
bit - never seen that
let's check the tinkling so they
tinkling so sickly we don't get you
their number of cystic ulis is southern
Africa we've got 2 4 6 8 10 12 14 16 18
18 so stickers that we have in this area
wall in in southern Africa but a few
species that we see some I haven't seen
yet or at all I'm gonna see maybe I'm
I'm gonna try reposition it hit back to
Tyler in the tent and she wants to talk
about lions apparently I did but look
who I found walking around outside
it's Herbie remember Herbie feel like
you guys haven't seen him for such a
long time now but it's great to have you
back welcome how was your holiday it was
good it was good what did you get up to
Herbie to improve my tracking skills
really did you do an assessment yes I
did what what level did you manage to
get he says that so casually let me just
quickly explain to you exactly a part
the tracking assessment so we do these
track and sign assessments obviously to
constantly keep improving ourselves now
you get you get level one which is I
can't remember the percentage now but
it's so it's the basically I'm leaning
at level two pretty confident tracker
level three you're unbelievable and then
if you get a hundred percent you
normally get invited to a special event
and have the opportunity to meet some of
the master trackers in the country so
well done level three that's very
impressive don't you think I'm so proud
of you you didn't tell me this is the
first time I'm hearing about it - so
that's fantastic
so now as you all know Herbie has always
got tricks up his sleeve I must going on
Bush walks will be hopefully gonna be
doing the bush walks - what is on the
ground
look what's on the floor there's tech
Safari
[Laughter]
hashtag please can we have to have
hashtag and then we missing the Safari
part maybe the car key will be the
Safari and then alive isn't that
honestly just one of the most amazing
things you've ever seen oh that is the
greatest thing hoobie did you want it
this way
okay we're they were saying it was other
way around
let's try again maybe we can track
someone can add Safari in there yes
there we go
why don't you take some screenshots and
you can help us out you can using your
most creative font you can add the
Safari I've even left a gap for you
and that'll be great and you can hashtag
actual Safari Live and Twitter so we can
all see it I think I need a new profile
picture this would be fantastic Herbie
how long did it take you to make this
this is great let's go I'm gonna put
this in my room can I have it please
guys I'm just taking it I'm going to
keep this for the rest of my life you
know that I'm gonna put it up on my wall
in my bedroom that is fantastic now and
how how long did it take you to make
that almost the whole day very very
fantastic of you her before for doing
that I'm so impressed I could never do
anything like that I'm at sir absolutely
hopeless so maybe I have a question for
you what are you most excited about
seeing when we go on our bush walks
lipids leopards you excited to track
them yes and well your favorites what
about finding lions because we've had a
problem with trying to find the lion's
lair they're too quick for us every time
we think we on the target and we're on
the tracks just a few steps behind
we never get them we need you I was
electric off any lands but at the very
same time with our shaking and chauncey
being restricted here because of these
lines crossing too
neighboring property we are just playing
a dirty game of food that we even hope
you agree so sneaky at the moment but
why do you think it is that the Lions
are not staying on the property anymore
and I know for sure that our lands there
are buffer the specialist and at the
moment we are struggling in finding
buffers in the property so don't be more
in the areas that we know and buffers
are always in that those particular
areas just like for now it's to our
south and also to our not fair enough
that's exactly so what I want to do now
is I said to you earlier that we were
gonna get some clips and put together to
have a look at what the Lions were doing
last year as Hobie said then groomer
pride our lion specialists Chantal if
it's possible can we play clip number
two and have a look and see what those
Lions actually got up to now it's a
young calf come on lines you can take
this down isn't this amazing
come on it's a little cut off the rest
of the herd of buffalo have raced away
unfortunately I think this is the end
look at this I think unfortunately that
this is indeed the end for this buffalo
calf you can see the male now going in
grabbing it by the throat it needs to
keep the calf quiet otherwise the herd
of buffalo are going to come back and
try and chase these Lions or well-done
lions well well done you can see he is
not letting anybody go to that carcass
which is gonna be a bit of a problem
because the females may gang up on him
in order to get a good feed Buffalo
actually tried to get up again I can't
believe it that it managed to gain that
strength perhaps with all the adrenaline
that's also rushing through its body and
then of course everybody came through
again and the males grabbed straight
hold of the throat to try and close that
jugular
now the liens haven't seemed to be doing
too much more damage to this Buffalo
just yet but we've got another lioness
who's joined in and the starting to feel
now that in my opinion was the best lion
vs. Buffalo searching I have ever had
and I've been very privileged to have
some of those sightings actually my best
ones have actually been here while I've
been at Wilders I've been very very
lucky how amazing was that hey really
good and again that's what Herbie said
they're like the lions here our Buffalo
is specialists so that's what they did
pretty much every single day last year
for as soon as I started working here we
would go out we would try and remember
where we saw the Buffalo from the day
before and we were almost guaranteed not
quite a hand of a saint guarantee but we
go in and we'd find these lines and they
either were taking down a buffalo when
we got there or they were stalking
although or they were already feeding on
it and that's sort of not the only
except there's so many of them there but
unfortunately until those Buffalo come
back and if they just following the
range just as the animals in Kenya are
doing going to the best areas where the
best grazing is that's where the Buffalo
at the moment and unfortunately because
of the late rains they haven't quite
returned yet whether they will return
before the next rains I'm not so sure I
really hope that they do because I'd
quite like to see our pride of lions
again I'd like to see how they grow
especially now with those six very
healthy Cubs that's going to be quite
interesting because they're getting to
the age now where they should start
hunting aren't there yeah so we had
another sighting I'll just quickly
mention this one it was really amazing
where I was fortunate I was at Halloween
last you should remember that drag where
I painted different faces different
animals on my face with eyeliner it was
quite interesting and we got to
experience the young uncle whom a Cubs
are only about when he was like five six
and seven months older the three
different letters and they actually took
down a young calf of that size obviously
that was the lionesses that first took
it done that actually I'm killed the
mother earlier that morning and the calf
was hanging around the dam so they took
that opportunity and also took it down
and then
the lionesses sat back once they'd
weakened the calf enough and the little
ones went in and they jumped on their
backs they were practicing sort of all
these maneuvers that they see the adults
doing and four lines at such a young age
to me it just goes wow how is that going
to affect their experience and hunting
Buffalo in the future and that's why I
can't wait to get back and start
following them and watching these little
ones really learn because now their jaws
are powerful that they're still small
but they could definitely do some damage
and actually participate once the
Buffalo goes down on the ground on
increasing the blood flow you've seen
her Lions also bite on the spine to try
and make the animal weaker so they'd
bleed out they will definitely be able
to contribute so herby have you got a
favorite lion vs. Buffalo sighting that
you've had since you've been working for
Wilder the same pride in Kuma's we're
following a bigger of buffalos and one
of the lionesses went for the fully
grown bull but he went on she went on
top of of him but the rest of the
buffalos they came back to help the
tagged one so eventually they managed to
chase of the nests Wow so it wasn't a
case of lions having their next meal but
the table's turned and the Buffalo
managed to chase the lines we're now in
that clip that you watch just a moment
ago some other thing actually happened
the whole herd came running back in to
try and rescue of course the young calf
but unfortunately they just weren't
quick enough and the lioness stood their
ground and charged back and ended up
sending the Buffalo running with her
tails between their legs and sadly one
less member but there's many of the cats
on screen as you know Byron's with
husana let's go and see what the three
of them are up to
well from the moment her sauna is
resting that's what he's up to and
likely because it is cool he still he's
lying out in the open even though it's
in the long grass but he is out in the
open and I can see that beautiful golden
light on him now
Jennifer yours is her son an
average-size for his age yeah yeah let's
suppose that is average size for male
lip at that age I'm slightly bigger than
a female um well I say slightly bigger
than a female slightly bigger than full
full grown female males get much bigger
they get about twice the size of a
female leopard so yeah I is oh it says
average size
rusty you asked when will the young
leopards leave their homeland find the
intera Tori sir rush me and I suppose
you mean the area or the area that their
mothers raise them in so with with
generally with young leopards so what
happens is firstly females can give
birth to anywhere between one and three
cubs with with leopards and with the
female what happens is if she has a
female cub for example she will give up
a portion of her territory for that
young female and that female will then
have to extend that territory at some
point by herself with the young males
and they generally get pushed out by the
by either the the female all the the
males in the area now all the dominant
male in the area will get pushed out and
it will be nomadic until he gets to the
age of about four five years old then
he'll probably start trying to set up a
territory for himself but Roshini you
must remember that the leopards become
independent at about a year and a half
so it's all quite some time before they
actually become dominant and set up a
territory for themselves with the
females might be a bit young younger I
have seen females at the age of three
mating and giving birth to two cubs and
three to four years old and and then
with with the males it's generally a bit
older but so about four four or five
years old before they start setting up
territory for themselves I've seen a
four year old going on five year old
leopard challenge a big male leopard for
territory and he came off second best
year he didn't he was quite a I suppose
you could say it was a fighter and he
went and looked for trouble
all the time and ended getting to a lot
of altercations with bigger dominant
leopards trying to challenge fulfill
their territory and this was done in the
south but you know from about four years
old he was looking to just set up
territory for himself but I think young
Isana probably gonna hang around for a
little while longer before he decides
and he
see try set up a territory it'll be fine
for now but when he does start st.
marking or trying to become territorial
I'm assuming his father ting gana won't
tolerate that would and will probably
push him out then at that age but at
this age he will still be tolerated
because he is a young leopard and
there's no threat Ricci leopards are
just solitary animals they may move
around by themselves the only time
you'll see leopards together is if it's
a mating pair of leopard sir male and
female or otherwise if a female has got
cubs and she's looking after those caps
generally there are solitary and it's
just the niche that they fall in nature
as a predator so you don't have groups
of leopards or a group of leopard is
known as a leap of leopards but you
don't find them in groups any any male
and female if they're mating
otherwise young cubs with the mother
I have seen I've seen leopards
interacting more than one leopard
interacting I've seen males a male
mating with two females at the same time
and I've seen two males trying to mate
with one female
now that is unusual very unusual but it
can happen right all its head back to
tinting tailor and see what tantalizing
tidbits
she has worse in the tent now I was
going to say that James was the king
earlier of alliteration scrap that Byron
is not the king of alliteration that was
fantastic I remember I made an attempt
once where I was trying to say saucy
safari and I don't know and it was just
an absolute disaster so two thumbs up
for you bone right now seems that we've
been talking about the drought and lions
and where are they when will they come
back that type of thing maybe we should
focus on the prey in the buffalo hang on
in essentials just lost her headphones
I'm just hooking them back on so I saw
that and I thought if it was me and
luckily it wasn't me that didn't that
had headphones because I would have
dragged monitors and the skulls would
have fallen down then the whole tent
would have collapsed
I just create that much drama now I've
placed this Buffalo on the table over
here and one thing that's very typical
with Buffalo skulls out in the bush is
that it's hard to find a completely
intact skull you always notice that
unfortunately the nose ends up getting
sort of well for lack of better words
chewed off I apologize I cannot sort of
master up the strength to come up with
anything better than there and that is
purely because when the Lions ever
attack their prey they've now pushed the
Buffalo down to the ground one lion will
always go to the start and try and
suffocate it like that so if my hands
are well the jaw of a line we don't have
the line scale anymore I'm afraid
otherwise I would have used the skulls
and demonstrated with them and it will
bite over like this closing down all the
skin onto the nasal cavity I'm pressing
those nostrils flat and then also
clamping the jaw shut in the same breath
so they can't open its mouth and breathe
it's a very slow process the other thing
is is that they will go through go for
the throat too and they'll try and crush
the windpipe and that's another
technique that normally they do a
combination of things it's not always
just one way they'll have some lines on
the back like I was describing earlier
they will be biting on the spine trying
to get the blood to flow get to get it
to weaken the Buffalo but it's really
amazing I have a look at this one
completely gone I reckon what's happened
here as well I don't think it was just
Lions that were feeding on this Buffalo
I think the hyenas came in afterwards
and had a go at - and as you know hyenas
have got very very powerful jaws very
strong teeth and are one of the few
animals that are able to digest large
shards of bone due to their amazing
digestive system and all the sort of
bacterias and things it's incredible and
I think that they were biting aware that
now there are also lots of things living
in here there's daddy longlegs I'm just
trying to see if I can maybe find any
any other spiders in here no it seems as
though the daddy longlegs are the ones
that are living in this Buffalo - right
we can put this one back down on the
ground my goodness I've done so much
reading not quite just collecting so
many skulls and well I need to put them
back because it James does a surprise
visit I'm going to be in so much trouble
can you imagine you'll come in here with
a stick probably something like a knob
thorn stick and start beating away and
all this type of thing so I'm gonna make
sure that I keep it clean and tidy and
also kind of find myself in a lot of
trouble anyways speaking about chains
it's great to have him on the show to
get we've definitely missing him around
yeah no never mind
we will go to him at some point it seems
as though
we've lost communication with Kenya so
that's alright that's okay James we'll
get back to you just now them but it
would be nice to go back to him
eventually and have a look right what
else have we got you should we know
we'll leave this here for a moment I
will at some point go outside as well
and and start collecting some more items
and there is another line clip that I
want you to watch which we were also
chat about a little bit later but it
seems as though James is ready earpieces
in he's hearing final control all the
way in the sabi sands and let's go to
him thinking hello everybody
sorry we're just a few issues with our
communications but I think we are live
good we got in amongst the herd not
around with those lions were we gave up
on them they're too fat and flat and so
we got in amongst us heard that is all
around us now and we're hoping that we
might find some lions we've now got the
other two things that we need signal and
ville de bist now we need signal
wildebeest and predators and then we
will have the trifecta
anyway I'll ask for to sort of pan
around and show you what's going on here
there we go you can see lots of little
bits all over the place vultures by the
Dozen and they still flying around even
at this time of the day when it's pretty
chilly
not very warm at all anymore and yet
they are still flying around and I think
that they follow these herds because
they they know that stuff is going to
get killed they also know that a lot of
these animals drop dead of their own
sort of work not of their own volition
but certainly by causes other than
crocodiles and vicious lions and cheetah
and that sort of thing and so they pick
up the scraps as they go and I think
that for the vultures this is a real
boon time they seem to be using that
term quite a lot this afternoon
certainly twice anyway so the other
thing that I'm listening to here or
listening for is you look at the marabou
stork and another vulture is whether or
not we can hear anybody's alarm calling
or see any that are showing signs of
some sort of distress
the ones around here of course are well
pretty much relaxed because you cannot
you cannot track here of course you
can't get out of the car the grass is so
thick that you can't see where lions
walked and so you really have to kind of
use various other methods of lion
detection and one of those of course as
we use it everywhere
is the alarm calling of animals you can
hear them doing their news you want to
know how many prides of lions there on
the Mara we don't know Ricci its
enormous it's of a thousand five hundred
and ten square kilometers at some
150,000 hectares I'll go through the
prize that we know of
we know the ole ole ola pride we know
the young Gama pride we know the maguro
pride we know the Paradise Plains pride
we know the Tsarina north pride which
could indeed be the same thing as the
Paradise pride Plains pride we have got
a V Egyptian goose pride the sausage
pride the border pride and that's just
on the Mara triangle which is one third
of the Maasai Mara the other side of the
river we've met the solace pride we've
met the Blackrock pride we've met the
rhonchi pride we have met the who who
else have we met I feel like this there
one or two more that we have met anyway
you can tell from what I've said there
that there are a great deal of Lion a
great number of lion prides in this area
and I think you're gonna find that as
this migration moves towards the north
the boundaries between those prior
territories are going to become more
blurred and then I think also you'll
have quite a lot in the way of nomadic
animals coming into and out of this area
sort of sneaking a meal here and there
so nomadic males who don't yet have
territories and that sort of thing
Marty shall we try and drive a little
bit let's see if we can maintain signal
and we'll try and drive along a little
bit
oh well chance I got ooh copy snazzy ah
there we go
ah snazzy you've got a question you say
what are these trees called these are
mainly two kinds of trees one a balun
itz gypte camp and the other a
shepherd's tree and I've just bought a
trees of the East African savanna and so
I'll find out more about those trees in
due course but those are the main ones
and they're not the flat-topped acacia
is that people think of when they come
to an area like this and I'm not I guess
those impressions come from the
Serengeti rather than the Maasai Mara up
here well the trying gets a bit closer
to some of the vultures I think that the
roof of rupaul's Griffon vulture which
is a very close relative of the white
fact I think he's a rather beautiful
fellow then we'll see if we can't get to
one lots of leopard faced vultures here
as well of course which are the biggest
ones and in fact if we look off to the
left they're just nice and level no try
and park nice and live live here we go
you can see trees full of vultures all
over the place and those ones were the
mottled backs other ripples Griffin's
there we go you can see the light
starting to fade slowly it's not really
late yet but there's quite a lot of
cloud in the West which means that the
sunset and the Western Sun that would be
hitting us normally is there well gone
behind the clouds there we are
and then just down below that fur go
it's gone now there was a hitchhiker on
one of these wildebeests and it was of
course not an ox picker but a bottled
Starling
see if I can't find another one of those
now normally the wattle starlings where
I'm from will fly around the feet and
pick up the invertebrates rather than
actually hitchhike there you want to
know when most of them are of vultures
nest I I don't know I guess I can find
out a few straightaway if you like let's
find out here on my I'll check my app
first and if I don't succeed there I've
got a very nice book as well a vulture
let's go with but let's go with my
favorite which is the roubles Griffin
see what it says no it's actually just
describes describes what it looks like
which of course is rather obvious
because I'm looking at it the nest and
cliff and rocky outcrops much like the
that's interesting much like the Cape
vultures all look at the rain
this is distressing really pointing the
camera ho just exactly where we were
thinking about going well we're not
gonna go over there now let me just know
that quickly okay look here at my other
book and see if I can't get a
satisfactory answer for what time of the
year they Bri eat there we go that's it
birds of the Masai Mara let me see if I
can't find something on the vultures
this is very sort of ominous feeling
evening this one on account of the rain
and the cloud we had a beautiful day
without any kind of cloud at all and
then really typically as the as the
afternoon started to started to fall so
the clouds began to build right page
number 14 years believers where I need
to be looking yeah we are no missus
mainly just an identification guide I'm
afraid so I can't tell you when they
breed I'm afraid
sorry about that now here we go breathes
in low densities usually nesting on top
of the catcher or desert palm tree but
it doesn't say when I suspect they're
fairly a seasonal you know there's
always a fair amount to eat here despite
the fact that obviously the migration is
not always in town I think this is more
kind of a bonus time than it is
something that everyone depends on for
their staple you know and that goes to
all the predators as well there's plenty
to eat here all the time and it's just a
kind of bonus time of the year and
you're wondering about the rarest
vulture species we can see in the VAR
Mara I suspect quite strongly that it is
the you can get Kenny good cape vultures
up here you might be able to if not the
Cape Valle to the white headed but again
I'm going to check that up for you
quickly
it's just have a look-see well I mean
you can get a palm nut vulture here in
theory but that would be so that would
be very rare indeed but I've yet to see
one here perhaps yeah you can't get
Egyptian vulture that would be very
unusual and now you don't find cape
vultures here are just quite interesting
you do get white headed they are pretty
rare though I mean their distribution
would indicate that they're not
particularly rare but I think you will
find them you'll find them pretty rare
so those would be my answers somewhere
between the white headed the Egyptian
and the palm nut you very visual palm
nut here it would be pretty a far out of
its distribution but it is possible and
I'm sure they have been seen here
all right we have with the flattest cats
in the Maasai Mara just some lions a
little while ago and now we are going to
carry on number two Byron would like to
tell you more about his spotted flat cat
well our spotted cat is laying down I
don't know why I don't know why but I
must be honest I don't I don't like the
term flat cat don't judge me everyone
but I I just I really don't like it I
think the other vehicles moved off so
that's a good sign the Sun is gonna
stand up now and he's gonna walk around
for us
it's my wishful thinking kicking in
there you know what patience as I said
I've said many times patience pays off
it's getting a bit chilly or not so we
gonna sit we can sit with him because
it's just so nice to be able to sit with
a leopard like this and he's rolling
around he lifts his head now and then
and as I said it's starting to cool down
so chances are he might decide to get up
and move around some more
that's what I'm hoping for no because
these other vehicles have left I don't
want to I don't want to I don't want to
miss out on anything I'm so I'm always
so scared that if I said if I said oh
you know what he's going to rest and
sleep here and then and he won't do
anything and we move and next thing
he'll get up and it's Murphy's Law he'll
get up and start moving and who knows
what he'll do or what he'll get up to
you
so
ricci you asking if leopards can die
from being malnourished yes i mean if
they don't get the food that they need
if they're hungry they're unable to hunt
they're not strong enough then then
definitely definitely be able or
definitely i'm died from from lack of
food or malnourished
raising
pointing out the little - what are the
other guides are we - yours hardly
leopards groom their kite well retain a
like any other big cats they'll just
clean and lick themselves now the big
cats like leopard and lion have got
they've got Bob like hairs on their on
their tongue they've got very very rough
tongues so by licking and cleaning
themselves they actually get I'm gonna
actually get a lot of the ticks and
fleas off of them he's lifting his head
now and then I don't know if he's gonna
let's watch it come on
but they do so just by licking they'll
clean themselves and groom themselves
very very well very thick tongues just
like a just like a lion the Lions gonna
incredibly rough rough time and so do
the leopards at these little hairs on
the tongue little barbs almost that make
it very very rough and you you'll see it
the probably the best example is when
you see these cats feeding on something
you know I'll often liquor caucus I'll
lick and clean some of the skin off and
they use that obviously then use their
tongues but you can hear and you can see
them actually pull the carcass with
their tongue just by licking it
especially the Lions you'll see a few
licks and all they'll clean an entire
patch of hair off the carcass and then
I'll start feeding
so I'm I'm not going to give another
alliteration for the tent but let's head
back to Taylor she's got a few caucuses
or and skulls that she'd like to show
you
I definitely have a carcass now I'm just
trying to you don't know if it's
actually gonna work because the wind is
not picked up and it's just blowing
everything around and what can I use I
need to play what can we use to shelter
what I want to do from the one I'm sure
of bones would work use that I need to
try and just get a bit of protection
over here is that gonna work because
it's the spider caucus that I want not
of cause it says to get listen that I
want to show you you know what I'm gonna
have to do we'll do that in the next
segment I have to play around and
unfortunately get it into a container of
some sort quite a deep one I think that
will probably protect from the wind
because it's not going to work now and
I'll also need to then take away the old
whip but I won't tell you which spider
it is just yet anyways we have another
clip which was quite interesting the
Lions Buffalo and elephant are you ready
to watch it because I am so I think
let's have a look at that one I think
it's clip number one not too far away
you could look at that much closer it's
this is incredible just again everybody
thought those sensitive viewers are
watching it's not always easy to see but
this is nature everybody so just just
bear that in mind please and there's
some elephant coming into the area now -
let's see what happens
and look at that managed to shake off
that lioness and get away now with this
elephant just off to the right you might
see it come into frame there we go
now you see the lionesses moving off
very quickly look at that isn't that
incredible
Buffalo managed to get away and the
elephants chased the lines off you see
lines do not I really like big elephant
I'm just gonna watch what does elephant
does no no no easy easy to move she's
just chasing that other line this don't
charge us see I don't want to know
[Music]
we're not here to hurt you see I don't
want to make too many loud noises and
sounds like us and the cutters doing sit
with these lines around this is just a
young elephant right welcome back
everybody you know live with us that
clip that you did you just see that
Byron had the privilege of sitting in
that siting I think I was last year
actually I remember I was also working
at that time I don't know what I had I
don't think I had something as exciting
as that but that was just a catch up
clip you're back with us remember
hashtag safari live with all of your
questions this is happening right now
now that is an amazing sighting to have
and I reckon with in a space of a couple
of months byron first headed off and he
had that incredible sighting then jamie
had a sighting where the lions were
feasting upon a buffalo which they
killed I think was the night before and
a group of elephants came in and chased
them off of a carcass and then the
elephant then investigated around the
carcass and then one evening you might
remember this - we had a similar
sighting we've set with them go home a
pride the whole day and little ones were
climbing up on the marula trees it was
so great was when the Cubs are still
quite young and we set off and they
started stalking the lionesses and I
said she' we're not gonna follow them
because you don't want to ruin the
chances of the hunt you always want to
give the animal an opportunity and then
we heard the distress calls and David
and I went racing down and then
unfortunately the gremlins got us and we
weren't able to continue but the same
thing happened just as you saw there
with fire and unfortunately the Buffalo
that they're caught died relatively
quickly it must have been extremely
weakened from the drought and you saw
that from that clip you could see a lot
of ribs you could start to see the spine
and all the vertebra so just shows you
how these how these animals
unfortunately suffered during the
drought the Predators however seem to
thrive until the white muscle disease
came about but that's we'll talk about
that a little bit later what I do want
to focus on of course is there when
something is being attacked by a
predator even if it's a fight amongst
the same species and make a lot of noise
they were in
de-stress a linen incredible how we
always say about the animals always
speaking the same language now as that
young buffalo bull was distressing and
saying and help a you know probably
calling other Buffalo the elephant's
heard that call and they came charging
in and said right we're not putting up
with this I don't know if you noticed
right at the end now one of the lions is
actually just hiding away in the bushes
just standing absolutely still now it's
not often that we've seen lions sort of
performing the freeze technique was was
one of the three very basic strategies
that animals will you to try and evade
predation that was very very interesting
to observe or something like that just
sitting there waiting elephant
completely forgot where the lion was was
distracted by all the vehicles moving
around
what a great sighting and handled so
well by Byron too and I'm sure he
probably still tells his story or that
particular sighting to all these other
guests that he's fortunate of taking out
on safari now one thing that me was
pretty incredible was did you see amber
eyes did you see how she took charge in
that entire sighting how she she got up
she made the first run at that buffalo
that young bull and then pounced on its
back and then held on for dear life and
it's very very important that's very
very risky and is very dangerous for a
lioness to do that because if it was a
healthy buffalo bull things could have
gone wrong he could have backed her off
and she would have fallen to the ground
and well let me tell you that's the
scary thing about buffalo is that they
don't stop they come back and that's why
we're on walks always so worried about
them and that's what they do to Lions
they will keep coming back and keep
Horning down into the ground with those
very very sharp tips these Buffalo
skills that we've got Jeremy bring this
to me see if I can bring this one down
or unfortunately I'll just use this one
it'll be easier we're quite old bulls
and if you look over here you'll see
that the tips of the horns are not
particularly sharp anymore that's not
going to do too much I mean it would be
very sore to have a buffalo using all of
its weight remember they can weigh up to
800 kilograms so almost a ton imagine
all that pressure pushing down on you it
would still hurt but when they're a
young football it's not quite needle
sharp but I'll tell you right now it
will hook into your skin and will rip
you in if you're not careful and for
mine is my careful obviously we try and
not bother the Buffalo too much and
they'll get themselves into a lot of
trouble and actually end up killing out
being killed by the Buffalo so that's
why they're one of the most dangerous
animals in Africa the Buffalo a force
not to be reckoned with let me put this
back now we have a question from Bobby
and that is should I sit down I don't
know what to do not up down up down
sorry Bobby you're wandering channel the
Lions power paralyzed the Buffalo by
biting on the spinal cord most certainly
but they're not doing it for that in
fact the reason why they are biting on
the spine like that is one of the main
reasons and you'll see they just chew
chew chew it causes a lot of bleeding
and when an animal like that is under
stress it's obviously getting hot it's
using a lot of energy and if you make it
bleed well then it's gonna weaken it
quicker as well you know what I think is
gonna happen as I feel yeah I'm on a
very unlabeled piece of ground there and
I thought if I de leaned back in my
chair which you should be able to do I'm
going to topple over and can you imagine
how much trouble I beef in from James I
reckon he'd probably fly in a hospital
oon to come and sort me out from be a
disaster not really are you wondering if
other herbivores will always help each
other and in a case like that no not
necessarily
and sometimes even Buffalo go hang on we
may be biting off a bit more than we can
chew we're gonna stand back and
unfortunately Bob you're gonna have to
take one for the team so I have a thing
but where they will where they can or
where they were where they can they will
come charging in and try and help I've
noticed though if anything it's normally
elephants that come to the aid of
various animals rescue and I've actually
had sightings as I have said many
different times where elephants charge
in and try and chase lions away when
they're trying to bring down a buffalo
so I don't know if anyone else has had
any other entrants maybe we can pass
this question along to byron
James - maybe they've had other
experiences where different prey species
have come in to assist I've actually
only seen it with with them you know
Buffalo elephants and lions I can't say
that I've seen any encounters of course
there's a the famous encounter of the
Kruger sighting where it was buffalo vs
crocodile vs lions vs buffalo again and
I mean she that little calf got away I
mean that's just an amazing sighting you
to have the apex predator in Africa
which is the crocodile not only does it
go after every single animal species it
doesn't discriminate from herbivore to
predator they'll eat it but they also
consider us as humans as food then when
the polar bears gotta watch out for them
so see it's imagine they're having a
sighting like that and that is a
possibility to have something like that
and that's the joy of Kenya you just
never know what you're going to see and
I think everybody is so excited about
the Maasai Mara and the Maya triangle
and everything that goes on in it but
we're gonna go across now not to the
Mara we're gonna head straight to won't
just down the road actually however if I
shouted the Saleen cat Byron might be
able to hear me he's still with us
Arnhem and I wonder if he's woken up
from his catnap I have actually woken up
Taylor and we still sitting with the
sauna but I dozed off for a little bit
but I am awake now I know Taylor was
meaning that referring to the leopard he
is so he's still resting and lying down
not interested in moving I think we'll
give it a few more minutes we're very
fortunate at least to get him moving
around and following him for a short
while before he decided to lie down
last we nice to spend time with the
lipid like us now I've just been
listening to the radio and doesn't sound
like there's too much else going on a
few vehicles and they've all just come
into our sighting with the leopard but
it doesn't sound like it's too much else
going on bad we'll drive around shortly
I think we've spent probably enough time
with them we'll see we'll see maybe who
knows he could get up fairly soon and I
know Taylor was showing you that
wonderful wonderful sighting of those
lions with the with the Buffalo and and
it was an amazing sighting it was really
interesting and then you see the
elephant come in and help the Buffalo
and I've lacked aliases I've only seen
Buffalo or elephant coming to help other
animals and usually it's more case'll
they smell the Predators they don't like
competitors now come and chase the
Predators exquisite bliss you were
saying asanas camouflage is amazing it
is indeed it blends in so well with that
dry grass
I do sometimes wonder though that these
animals when we are round are wonderful
if they don't even though they're not
threatened by us and they are relaxed I
wonder if they decide to lie down and
rest like this when the vehicles are
around as soon as we leave them they
they then get up and start moving and I
think it does happen from time to time I
think our presence does disturb them a
little bit to an extent although saying
that I've viewed leopards hunting and
with them not worrying about the
vehicles at all but I think if generally
if they're just moving around if they
can they lie down they probably do that
because they don't want to be followed
anymore perhaps I'm not sure
or James
good question okay you say which
commonly used fact or commonly used
story about leopards to our fine false I
[Music]
think I think the one and this is
actually a funny story so I think the
the one is is that leopards
only move around at night and and are
mainly nocturnal that is false I can
guarantee you that is false now a funny
story a guest of mine
guest that I've been taking on Safari or
since 2009 I think and he is so
passionate about leopards and would
specifically request to look for
leopards and he was at a dinner party
last year sometime
and and they were having a conversation
about nature and and wildlife and they
the the topic of lipids came up and he
spoke about the lipids and and this lady
then sitting are but you know you don't
see leopard stirring the Darryl and he's
you definitely do they move around
during the day too
no no that's an absolute lie you do not
see leopards during the day he got quite
upset he went she said okay all I'm not
going to argue with you anymore because
him and I have been viewing leopards for
years and seeing leopards move during
the day many many times I mean we saw
her son of walking around at up was 3:00
in the afternoon
oh yeah opposed to equality for so it
just shows you and I've seen leopards 10
11 o'clock in the morning going off and
hunting they definitely do move around
during the day we just probably don't
see them that much so James I think
that's one that I can say is is
definitely not true trying to think of
what else what other what other facts or
stories of people
mention about leopards that there are
untrue based on what I've seen I've been
very fortunate I've seen well there's a
little stretch that's usually a good
sign
stretching I don't know if he's but
stretching and yawning with most of the
cats in general is a sign that they may
potentially get up and start moving
around they could also just get up move
two meters change position and lie down
again
Barbara you asked is it possible to to
judge or gauge how large a cat will be
judging on its poor size and Barbara oh
that's tough look Barbara I mean we can
we can judge obviously whether it's a
lion or leopard track based on based on
the pore size so we can tell it it's
either female leopard or male leopard or
a lioness or a male line now Barbara in
terms of the actual size its I don't
think so not necessarily but but I'm
sure that's pretty accurate enough to be
able to tell you whether it's a lioness
or a male line you know that's that's
pretty close however I've seen I mean
I've seen some male lions with very
small tracks now there's a coalition
that we used to see on London Eye z4 for
many years the merging galan and the
tracks are actually quite small
occasionally the trackers would look and
they'd almost second-guess themselves if
it was a lioness or a male lion but but
yeah so some Lions might have small
attract some leopards male leopards
might have smaller tracks in others so
but I think in terms of judging look
whether it's a male or female you should
be able to get that right
so Barbara I think yeah you can kind of
have a guess at whether it's it's a
large cat or a small cat in terms of
actual size probably not I don't know
all right well to be honest I think we
have spent enough time with this male
leopard it's it's been a wonderful
sighting and nice to spend time with him
and he seems quite relaxed but I think
we'll leave him we'll give him his
privacy and allow him to carry on with
whatever he feels like doing all drive
around starting to lose a bit of light
now to maybe have some luck with some
owls but they say back to Tyler in the
tent and we'll see you soon it's lovely
some nice ice cold water of course now I
have managed to get my spider situation
sorted I believe that if I look like I'm
moving in slow motion innocence is just
gonna change some camera settings am I
making you seasick no not anymore it's
fixed right so I actually had a serious
argument with the with the spotter and
the whip because it was a nightmare it
kept getting stuck to my fingers and
then it kept getting stuck to my knife
and then the stick and then I'd think
I'd have it right then the wind would
blow over
even though I put it in a container
right so can we please go to the
microscope how cool is that
look at that beautiful and even an
essential missing in essentials words
were did you just say are sweet eh well
there we go that's exactly what it is I
don't know how sweet a spider can be
I've never eaten one before should we
try it this is not an actual spider
though it's it's just the exoskeleton
and this is actually a sex spider now I
seem to talk about sex spiders quite
often mainly because they attack my
brother all the time and I've told you
many story so I shan't bore you any more
with my four other versus sex spider
incidents
and Ben who's only eight years old
you're actually wondering do we have any
spiders well it's like I said it's not
alive Ben so this used to be as part of
a spider it's it's old skin so it melted
now it's very important many different
animals are chair molt we see a lizard's
molting we see snakes molting we see
lots of different insects molting and
then of course the arachnids the spiders
do exactly the same thing and if they
don't molt they can't grow any bigger
I'm kind of glad though that we don't
molt
as humans can you imagine that would be
terrible we're a leopard molting but
there is actually a couple of things I
really wanted to show you on the
microscope if that's okay if we can go
back there just so that I can have a
look so I can just talk about a few
things there we go so the reason I know
that it is a sac spider is very very
easy to of course notice if you look at
its mandibles look at that completely
black and that is typical of the variety
of sac spiders as you get across the
globe and then of course they are
normally that sort of cream ish color
now it was quite interesting how a sac
spider actually has two shaded skin or
something and to be honest I don't
really know too much about so I
apologize in advance I'm going to try
and explain how they do mold but I shall
be doing more research to find the
proper terms so cs5 I actually have a
bit of a phobia of spiders but this
one's okay so what happens is I'm gonna
try and get a stick in here now no I
think if I try and get a stick in here
it's gonna be an absolute disaster so
you can see that it's all hollow and
it's just the the outside of the the
skeleton now when they prepare to Malta
faceook aliy like they need to pop out
of their own skin so you can imagine
this is a very dangerous state too
because they can't properly defend
themselves when there are multi so
they're vulnerable to predation as well
anyways they increase the the hemolymph
so that's insect blood or spider blood
they don't have blood like you and I
have and by doing that they increase
this sort of heart rate as well and then
they're able to burst out
that skin and then in between the old
exoskeleton a new exoskeleton it's quite
interesting there is something called
molting fluid I'm not exactly sure what
molting fluid consists of that's
something that I want to do dive into
and do a whole lot more research about
but they secrete it and that's to help
create a gap between the old and the new
excess skin and I suppose it also and
helps with sort of trying to slip out of
it a lot easier and then I thought to
myself what happens to that molting
fluid afterwards because I've read about
the molting flu before so quickly popped
it into the interweb and they said
parently the spider then reabsorbs it
which is quite interesting but I just
found that absolutely fascinating but
you can come back to me now I thought
you'd like to have a look at the sex
spider but remember you don't actually
want to touch the spider at all because
they have a cytotoxins so if it does
bite you
it can cause necrosis of the skin
luckily for us you're not probably not
going to die from a sec spider bite
unless you are completely careless and
you just there to get infected and
you'll get a secondary infection and
that's often what might end up causing
you to end up in hospital so so don't do
that just keep those wounds nice and
clean and it was also a very nice
example of the web don't you think you
could see why they were called sack
spiders it's a thin flat web unlike that
small little spider we had in the grass
using lots of strands that one was
almost a sheet and it actually made it
in the corner of the tent but well it
wasn't being used anymore so I just
boast of it we had a look at it for
education right let's go back across a
to Byron it seems as though he is left
wasana he said something about owls and
he's been hooting about them all day
let's go see if he's managed to find one
well we'll try best tailor we did leave
a sauna is still lying down resting so
I'm sure you'll get active fairly soon
may or may be late to this evening stop
moving around the temperatures
definitely dropped why I think it's
gonna be I think it's going to be a cold
one tonight a jacket where should we go
Creek I'm trying to think
oh we were we were asked to check the
genital or the Jenner to tree or the
tree with a Janet in it okay I'm gonna
try free will they'd see Forte hold on
there is no genital unless it got clever
and is hiding from us I mean it's
possible that it changed trees changed
areas maybe I don't know I don't know no
Janet in there at the moment
unfortunately I was really happy when I
did find that Janet but looks like the
Janet he's too clever for us
it's okay we'll see what else you can
find 20 think which way we should go was
a lot of elephant tracks here now
wandering these elephant headed looks
like they possibly went south across our
boundary maybe we still find him
chatty chatty Meg you wanted to see
elephant and I hope you heard my
explanation of the well in hippo
scenario and distant cousins though
hippos and whales I'd still find that
bizarre I can't believe it
like I said I think we go that far back
everything is a distant cousin or some
sort and as I said even even James and I
would then be distant cousins we should
actually we should actually send him
that that comments and see what he how
he feels about that I can just imagine
James's comments
he's probably probably trying to throw
himself under the Land Rover as we speak
[Laughter]
[Music]
cynic you asked what is a Janet's baby
called
it's called a baby Janet I actually
don't know see like if I do you
obviously mean is that is that a cab or
a pup or something like that
wow these elephants are three I can see
that brokers branch which way did they
go
let's see if I can find them let's see
neck Janet Janet
I wonder oh there's some dwarf mongoose
up ahead
let's see if we can see them hold on and
see neck let me check I've got a feeling
it's it I've got a feeling it's a Janet
pop I've got a feeling it's a Janet pop
don't quite meet let me first double
check let me see I'm not I'm actually
not sure I don't know if I trust Google
apparently Google says it's called a kit
never heard that term before antenna
said so - okay I believe Taylor I
believe Taylor so let's just see what
this a reproduction younger born see
this book again doesn't give me any
information on that so apparently it's
called a kit no why why would it be
called a kits it's not it's not related
to cats
um anyway that's a term it and that is
used get ki t so see neck that's what a
young Genet is called a baby genetic kit
and you see that so I love this yeah
we're always we're always learning
something I love and really enjoy Safari
live and especially all the viewers that
send in the information and that
afterwards if we if we perhaps don't
know because it's funny it doesn't
matter how long you have been working in
the bush
I've been guiding for you will always
find something that you've never seen
before that you don't know we're
constantly learning and that's what is
so fascinating about this this job and
why I love it so much and why I enjoy
getting people out into Africa because
there's always something new doesn't
matter how many times you come how many
times you go on safari you're always
going to see something new and something
different and we're going to learn
together and that's the beauty of nature
I think and that's wonderful so it kits
as a young Janet thank you
Taylor and Google
where all these elephant Oh they've been
they've been quite naughty they've been
throwing branches around the trees
pushed over and it looks like it was
some wallowing and that going on have a
look at this these elephants went to
town in the mad wala now you can see
these see how it's definitely been
they've been splashing mad on themselves
you can see signs of their elephant
tracks in there you can see how the mud
has been pushed aside so they've been
rolling splashing themselves and I can
just see the big footprints that's why I
know it is definitely elephant but only
elephant would create that amount of
could we call it damage or that amount
of mud to be thrown around other animal
would would wallow and and and make that
amount of mess would have been great to
see that maybe we can so find the
elephant to nose
I wonder where they would have gone
all righty then wall we will try and see
if we can find the elephant let's head
back to Taylor in the tent yes I have
not gone anywhere I'm still tending
Taylor I'm just remembering to put my
multi-tool away because that's how they
get lost or in my case I get taken away
from me at the airport lost any of those
that way now we're two different types
of thorns here I'm trying to not freak
myself I get them cool very sharp we'll
just have a little look at them I want
to actually put them out of mine
under the microscope to have a closer
look should we do that yes I think let
me let me take them back let me put them
down yeah right let's get rid of the
dung oh hang on sorry I'm just scraping
away I will get to the microscope now
mmm wait I've got to try and concentrate
yeah don't move stay ok let me see if I
can get this in focus Wow ok
let's go to the microscope this is
impressive that is what I'd imagine a
philosoraptor x' claw to look like which
is a dinosaur for those of you who don't
know what a velociraptor is and it's not
a Velociraptor claw of course that is
the thorn the hooked thorn of an oblong
tree isn't that very impressive now that
can quite easily make you bleed should
we you will do a little test just now I
will sec sacrifice myself for an
experiment we'll see which which the one
is sharper I think that that is pretty
pretty sharp now they've got thorns like
that sort of opposite each other going
all the way up the branches which is
quite nasty now you can imagine that
would be not very sort of nice so that
hooks onto your clothing nevertheless
when it pierces your skin now I'm gonna
trade it because there's another thorn
of course that I had in my hand that I'm
going to put underneath
and then we're going to do an experiment
afterwards we're gonna see how this goes
oh wait I have to actually might have to
raise this one a little bit yeah a
little bit because it's thorn no no you
have to stay there
oh my stay now this is a tricky one
because there's this from the buffalo
thorn and it's got two different types
as long as it's got a straight thorn and
a hook thorn so to try and get them in
the same shot trying to balance the
stick could be quite tricky
so please just bear with me I know it
has to go even higher let's try that
come back into the camp so difficult I
promise you probably all laughing at me
but it is it's so tough no no that's not
showing the angle that I want well we
may have done my experiment without me
even asking okay let's do this one's not
gonna work so what I wanted to do is I
wanted to see which was sharper so I
said this is for science and so on the
on the buffalo thorn
you've got the straight thorn and you've
also got the hook thorn on the other
side so why they call it the Huq and
stick and you can imagine now both of
them are equally as sharp but the one
that I'm most afraid of is not actually
the hook thorn this time is the straight
one because it's the one that always
gets and always the one that pricks you
the little hooked ones are the ones that
normally rip your clothing so where are
we going to test we test on my face I
probably have my hands also very dirty
please don't judge me right now because
I was digging and you can if you look
look on my table let me just defend
myself very quickly look what is here
you see all of that dung antelope dung
from a parlor - in Yala
- daycare and Steinbach is all on the
table so that's what I've been digging
through them so that's why my hands look
like they do but we're gonna prick my
finger we'll just pretend that I'm
shaking my sugar levels I'm too scared
[Laughter]
I'm a little baby even though it's just
a tiny little pink print prick so I
pushed it in and then it started hurting
so I stopped
let me just see how much sharper so it's
pretty sharp but I reckon
I think maybe this could be a no maybe
it's just because my thumbs are now so
tough from digging in the dirt
that my hands have become just one
callus and they're too tough for neither
thorns okay well that's not working
oh well anyways they normally do work I
pricked myself on them all the time
anybody that's come on Safari either has
a been driven through a knob thorn
branch or a buff probably more a buffalo
thorn tree by they guide or if you're
like me you just seem to stumble over
them all the time exquisite bless you
say that there's a strong word you said
that I'm mutilating myself for the
viewers
not quite mutilating Michelini is a
seriously strong word I was just
pricking my finger but as you saw I was
too much of a [ __ ] what will do is the
next time I do a bush walk I'll just do
what I normally do and I'll probably end
up with a scratch or two it's impossible
I've got scars all over my legs from the
amount of branches that I normally kick
back into myself I think I've actually
shown you them before and like I said
when you go on safari whether it's a
bush walk away in the Chi somebody
always ends up being tangled in a
buffalo thorn oh well I'm so sad that I
was too much of a [ __ ] to do my science
experiment to see which thorn was
sharper oh well
it's go across to Byron now and I'm not
sure what he's up to
it's starting to get dark the Sun is
definitely set is that spot plowed out
yet we'll have to go and see
you're just a thorn in my side that's
all you ever were don't tell James are
saying but I thought it was appropriate
because Taylor was testing the sharpness
of the thorns
Taylor testing thorns not quite
alliteration rust is making funny noises
that's not good so we just driving
around no sign of those Ellie's I don't
know where they disappeared to you maybe
we bump into them tomorrow morning at
least there'll be two of us out to gain
that I think you're mistaken yeah
so sensor is back from the Mara I'm so
Taylor and I will be on the vehicles
tomorrow what's what's the date tomorrow
is tomorrow the it's one of the first no
it can't be
tomorrow 31st I guess I would lose track
of time are two days
creig shall we try finding owl I was
really I was really upset yesterday with
that scoffs I couldn't believe it
spotted it and then it disappeared
machine-gun nest I'd love to see a
martial Eagle - we haven't seen a
martial Eagle for quite some time I
doubt we'll see one now this time of
thee this time of the evening but but
they are around so maybe maybe in the
next few days we'll see one we'll try
keep a lookout for birds of prey I was
saying the other day or yesterday we
haven't seen too many birds of prey
lately but then we saw battle ear we saw
Tony Eagle this morning from the tent I
saw their tawny eagle flying over with
the lilac breasted roller bobbing and
chasing it away I will see maybe who
knows who knows but I'd love to see a
martial Eagle it's my favorite bird
absolute favorite bird although these
little owls are starting to creep in
a lot of a lot of wonderful birds around
always nice to see them let's see I'd a
better spot an owl tonight before Craig
does he keeps rubbing it in and he
teases me when we get back to camp it's
very awkward in front of all the other
staff members
[Laughter]
and there's a koron
there's a Quran see if we can see it
just just disappear dad you know what I
don't think we're gonna see that Khurana
it landed in the long grass can you see
it
that Quran was so well camouflaged I
don't think we'll see it scenic you
asked what types of owls do we see in
the sabi sands scenic we see giant eagle
owl Oliver Rose eagle owl or what I
learned this morning also known as the
monkey eagle owl monkey white owl monkey
white monkey eagle owl - giant --all
burrows eagle ow
he spotted eagle owl we also get white
face cops are born our pulse spotted
outlet African barred outlet and African
scops owl that's seven I have we have
seen this was a few years ago but a
grass al we did see grass owl out here -
down the southern part of the sabi sands
that's eight species of grass or of owls
that I can think of trying to think am I
missing one am i missing one I think
that's it we'll have a look at good
evening good someone that's just joined
us beautiful male in Yala so eight
species of owl that I can think of let
me see what double check myself if you
can think of any other owls that I
haven't
I think that's about it the only ones
that I haven't seen here in the sabi
sands of the Pels fishing owl the marsh
owl the Cape Eagle Owl and the wood owl
the rest I've seen here and those are
the only owls we get in southern Africa
so so actually a great amount of great
variety of owls around unless you see
these male in y'all is browsing
as sorry until you said the or Lauren
were and say that this melon yalla has
got our Lauren where you say this this
in yalla has got spas stripes not that
many well the males the straps aren't
always that clear I'm not nearly as
clear as that on the female but it does
look as if those straps are quite
widespread they they it's definitely
quite a large gap between each strap you
guys think there's another one but TR
the males generally our Lauren where the
males generally don't have very
prominent stripes so but those ones did
look likely where a few a lot fewer and
wider apart which is quite interesting
there's a hornbill
so Craig erotic Adele you asked if I
prefer the night or the evening safaris
or the morning morning safaris Adele I
don't know I get asked this a lot and
I'm not sure I I don't know I I must be
honest I think I I think I prefer the
the morning drives generally because
it's exciting to find fresh tracks and
trying to look for animals and
especially in winter it's cooler and you
get animals moving around for lot longer
in the morning although the afternoons
you get to stop for sundowners so I
don't know I I think I think I would
have to say the morning but it's it's
difficult it's difficult
indulge us would my best after-dark
experiences that's a personal question
[Laughter]
okay Adele best evening experience I am
you know what the doll I've had Wow oh
it was actually not with guests but with
family we were on safari and we had I
took took family out into the Tom avati
who's staying there and we had we had
four male lions around our vehicle and
they were roaring all at the same time
that call
Adele it is unbelievable to hear lion's
roar but to have them close up is just
extra special and these these Lions
roared for us a number of times and
we're basically surrounded by these male
lions calling and for me that's by far
one of the best sightings I've ever had
just just because of the I think the the
sound the experience being there with
them also because I was with family and
friends it it was just wonderful
absolutely perfect so that was I think
one of them stands out by far as one of
my best sightings not just not just even
exciting and like I said just for a
number of reasons but but to hear lines
calling back and is just amazing
especially in their circle eyes and at
night we would sit the lights off
completely and and listen to these lions
roaring around us
Craig are you looking for owls
Kraig's is is looking for everything
thank goodness with some high-end
attracts a lot of elephant tracks all
over these roads but I haven't seen any
elephant yet probably move through here
during the course of the day but there
are there are hyena tracks heading down
the road too
all right well we'll carry on our search
for owls and maybe a high note ooh let's
head back to Taylor in the tent who is
it God known accenture there it is hang
on we have a daddy longlegs I found it
in one of the skulls now it's a young
daddy longlegs spider and it's missing a
leg that's actually quite interesting
and just been watching how it's very
capable to move around without an eighth
leg are you going to stay there this is
the hard part because it's still alive
it crawls but it is so beautiful so let
me just try and stay stay spider please
we want to see you
see if it's gonna wear see I want to
show you just say cuz it's running now
so now you can see that this is live
otherwise I would have given you
different it's actually quite funny
maybe put this microscope in focus and
maybe we'll just see it run across as it
can feature like one of those live
wallpapers that she gauges see okay
we're on the microscope there's no
spider there just yet good no hang on no
no no no spider go down go back in your
little plastic container we mmm there
you go alright sorry it's coming it will
come your way it's going to go there now
I suspect okay I'm going to shift it sit
still here it is moving her out walk oh
good
look at that that's amazing you see that
technique that it's doing what it was
doing there how it was shaking
vigorously so that that sort of
gyroscope technique now that's a
technique that they use of daddy
longlegs this is the underside of the
spider gee this is not the topside of
the spiders cleaning his eyes by the
looks of it with these peytie pulps now
what they do there is they sort of shake
themselves on the web and hopefully the
idea behind it is that if they have been
spotted by shaking themselves and moving
very very quickly and whatever was
trying
to feast upon them would then lose focus
and not be able to spot it isn't that
amazing nah I'm just trying to figure
out how I can angle this even better
probably all laughing me I'll get it in
focus now oh we're just gonna have to
look at it in the bottom corner like
that but it's very pretty like I said
it's a small one it has lost a leg but
it is doing fine
it'll be okay and I was really hoping
we're gonna see it walking around
because it's got these beautiful sort of
silverish white striking markings on its
body but I will release it don't worry I
will put it back into its skull where it
belongs I didn't want to use a fully
grown daddy longlegs spider because it
was actually quite difficult to even fit
this little thing in in the jar I'm just
trying to shuffle it around again
there we go that's all I wanted now I
need to put it in in focus
Ying oh I really wish it would turn
around but I'm just happy that it is
still how cool is that I love looking at
spiders under the microscope not in
essentia this is obviously her first
time in the channel she's had three
chains now and she just said how amazing
it was she didn't realize how beautiful
a spider could actually be I really
liked that there was a fantastic comment
that you made in a century because it is
true they are totally beautiful hmm oh
boy he said that this was a jittery
spider it is indeed now what it's doing
now is it's trying to clean itself it's
you can imagine the type of dust and all
sorts of things that it would have
collected didn't like that what that
little bit of grass did you see they're
put in between is love them no I won't
be having that thank you and it's not
trying to eat those butts of debris it's
just trying to get rid of them
it was very dusty when it came out of
the impalas car it wasn't yeah it was a
impalas skull that I I found it in and
then there's those are some egg sacs but
we need to try and dig them out at one
point it'll take some time not from the
spider from another spider
now gentlemen you're wondering if the
leg will grow back on the daddy longlegs
spider
I reckon yes it will especially once
that molt screws remember we've been we
were talking about molting with a sac
spider this is the sort of very young
one it's so small it's smaller than my
well it's about the size of my thumbnail
that's including its legs so you can
imagine how little is because daddy
longlegs I've got exceptionally long
neck legs as their name suggests I think
once it regenerates again
so once it moult's that leg will start
to grow how great was that I'm so
excited about that little slided worked
out very very very well it it took a lot
of patience and trying to get it to sit
still and at one point in a sentient
shot let me she said I killed it because
it was dead the bottom of the container
and then I said to her this is all a lot
of the stuff is all new because you
haven't spent much time in the bush I
have you in accenture but and I'm gonna
put out on camera as well before before
the show end so you can see what in the
scene she looks like and I said no
actually this is an amazing process
where it's called death feigning where
they well pertain to die so they
hopefully that their predator loses
focus and was amazing it just curled up
into a little wall like that
and then all of a sudden the wind oh I'm
back again welcome you know the spiders
show and then all for carried on
wriggling around well I need to release
a spider put it back in it's in Pilar
skull where it will be much happier
thank you very much for cooperating
let's go back across two biceps McGee
and all the wonderful other nicknames
that we get to call him
biceps McGee when did I become Scottish
Taylor
it ain't maybe maybe we should get you
out of there I'm trying to have a look
at the spotlight right now now there are
often owls around here when you hear
them from time to time just need to find
them
so those son of Bush babies anyway I've
been trying to look but my son sorry
Craig no sign of Bush babies
Tucker you're five years old hello
Tucker good evening while it's good
evening for us not sure way in the world
you are I'm assuming you in the United
States Tucker you asked are there any
vowels that sit on the animals like some
of the birds do like the oxpeckers
Tucker they aren't no so the owls
wouldn't sit on animals at all
they wouldn't feed on any of the ticks
or any of the insects and other animals
so we don't we don't see we don't see
owls sitting on the animals at all owls
will perch in trees and they'll swoop
down and try and catch rodents or
insects even some little lizards during
the day they'll try catch them on the
ground while we were sitting with
hasanah
actually I did get to see a little what
I thought was either bushveld gerbil or
a or a little elephant shrew perhaps
that ran through the scurried through
the grass very very quickly but there
was a little rodent that ran through
this so those little owls would be
looking would be looking for that those
little creatures rather now we looking
very carefully for silhouettes
spazz you asked what species of Bush
babies do we have in the sabi sands so
we have the lesser Bush baby and the
greater Bush baby more also known as the
thick tailed Bush baby that's the large
one the thick tail Bush baby and then
the lesser Bush baby is the one that is
more more abundant that's the one we see
regularly the little ones those little
Bush babies those are the ones that we
see more often would be great to get a
glimpse of an owl somewhere now
okay Craig do you want to carry on
checking silhouettes I'll see if we can
spot anything in the bush
I mean I think it's about time we find a
civet or a bush or a honey badger
now last night we actually had what
sounded like well a few little Scott
Sal's calling not far from Kemp's and
maybe maybe we can still find one I've
got a few more minutes
sorry I'm just listening I thought I
heard an alcoholic so Craig pointed to
the left and Craig it does sound like a
pill spotted I'll it's actually it's a
folktale drongo that's calling and I've
been caught out before like at the
folktale drongos they often give a
little whistle that sounds similar to
that of the pill spotted owl but that's
definitely a folktale wrong I just heard
a chirp from it now the folk tale drug
they imitate the owls for some reason
now scénic sorry Chantelle just give me
C next question again please yes so
scenic we do indeed have elephant true
in the sabi sands we do see I have seen
before I've been sitting with with lions
actually and and I've seen an elephant
true come running past well there's some
bats flying around that's not what we're
looking for his jaw goes it's amazing
that the whistle that they do to imitate
but then every now and then they give
that that little like scratchy screech
that the drongo gives it could that's
very strange sounds just like a little
scopz and sorry just like a pill spotted
owl I've been getting so tongue-tied
with these owls at the moment I keep
referring to scops owl as a pulse
spotted owl and a pill spotted owl is a
scopes are just too many owls
now this is the tree we saw house cops
all in last night I wonder I wonder if I
play my cool cuz last night played the
cool and and these scopes ow did come
out I don't know if it was that's the
sound that we listening for
scoffs I'll and then I'll play the pill
spotted all for those of you haven't
heard it that's the scops owl and then
the spotted owl
there we go listen to this no that's a
proper build up builds up to a whistle
sometimes they'll just do this for a
while when they build up and they'll
stop then sometimes they'll either end
with the whistle you hear that so that's
the pull spot it up
captain awesome use you asked if I can
find your chameleon
I'd love to you I'd love to but I do
think that the chances of that happening
are very slim at the moment with it
being winter and not nearly as active in
winter
snazzy generally it doesn't rain in
winter not not very much at all now and
then we might get a drizzle if we're
lucky now the other morning we actually
had a drizzle Tristan and Ellie were out
of Drive and and they had a light
drizzle what just heard something
chirping over here so it says he yes
there and we had had a little bit of
drizzle but it's very unusual for this
time of year to get any rain in this
part of the country it's very dry man
and then you might get you might just
get some maybe a day with it's overcast
maybe a light drizzle all right well
let's carry on our search for these
little owls maybe we get lucky let's go
back to the tent
find out what Taylor's up to and is she
excited about dinner
now not particularly though I love
Amanda's cooking but I'm not very hungry
tonight I think I might give it a
nervous skip anyway so could I've got
her be here oh it's quite a heavy skull
I know yesterday some of you are asking
about that big skull that had a very big
smile I think was this the smile you're
referring to Oh crying its teeth that
must be a sign of agitation just strikes
this is a zebra skull well we think it's
a zebra skull it was actually this this
we didn't find out in the bush and it
was from a taxidermy but it looks very
similar to a horse skull but I suppose
they're in the same malaria quizzes in
the end on the Ecuador day aren't they
yep
so I'm sure it's exactly the same thing
they did say it was a zebra I don't know
if they said virtuals or Cape Mountain
zebra it didn't really as specify my
beautiful nonetheless me try and take it
apart without breaking it
well races for my goodness look at these
teeth I'm always say that you got to be
careful of zebra because not only a lion
actually be killed by something like a
zebra and with their powerful feet but
they've got a very powerful bite now
they wouldn't necessarily bite a lion
but they've definitely bite other
stallions when they are fighting and I'm
sure the maize bites back to when they
get annoyed every now and then but look
at that that's amazing not just to try
and describe to you how sharp this
actually is I reckon if any of you
anyone have been bitten by a horse
before then you'll know exactly how
sharp their teeth are and I'm gonna
horse bite me once before I actually
drew blood it was that shot made a shot
made more of a bruise than anything but
very very important and then lots of a
look at the murders okay great and
murders are very important for grinding
down food of course so there is no
shortage of molars shall we count them 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 so six molars
on the the top jaw on either side the
for the back part of the jaw and then
we've also got some smaller sort of
molar light here one two three four five
six on the bottom one two three four
five six
okay there we go so that's pretty easy
in fact so at the back of the jaw top
and bottom six on either side it's quite
interesting actually didn't know this
I'm learning now as well and then a top
and bottom closer to the front of the
jaw we've got 1 2 3 4 5 6 and then 6 on
the bottom as well pretty cool I think
it's quite amazing now Paul you're
wondering if these animal skulls and you
try and realign it again or quite light
most of them not all of them some of
them are quite heavy the Buffalo skulls
are particularly Lavy
and so are elephants but I think it
depends on the bone density density but
you can see that I mean it's this
probably weighs about I'm just trying to
think how many how many of these could I
do little reps before my arm gets tired
I reckon listen that's where about 2 and
1/2 know maybe even more maybe closer to
5 kilograms just shy of 5 kilograms so
about 11 pounds or so it's not
particularly liked but then again it's
not over the top heavy but I mean let me
do some rearranging him let's make it
face the right way please don't fall off
because you will bring everything else
down with you right I did this I was
playing here and tried to make a pyramid
of bones that's heavy an elephant as
well but this is the one I'm after shall
we move the jars in the center because I
reckon I'm gonna I'm gonna knock this go
away and Paolo we know we love you but
we don't want to look at you right now
this is heavy this probably weighs close
to you about my goodness maybe 12 or so
kilograms I mean it's just all so
awkward to carry but this is from an
elephant and if I feel like the bone is
almost not quite petrified but it's
definitely I think a lot heavier than
what it would be and not to me when I
see something of the size and the bush
I feel like Fred Flintstone has been
around and Wilma had cooked him a nicer
steak of some sort from maybe a
brontosaurus
we're always saying if I see these
massive bones now it's actually uncommon
to find big elephant bones and things
like that around and the bush shall be
very lucky that and well it's not no
that's very sad it's not very good that
we see these bones we obviously don't
want to see big elephants taken down
they're my favorite animal of course but
lucky for us this one died of natural
causes and then we went and collected it
anyways I hope you enjoyed the 10th day
something a little bit different I quite
enjoyed watching those clips brings back
memories from last year where and
hopefully the gormers will return and
we'll be able to make new memories but
I'm going to send you across to am I
going to I don't know who I'm going to
Maura I am oh that's a surprise right it
must be quite dark now in Kenya so let's
go across to him and I wonder if James
is wearing his snazzy red jacket wasn't
because the chef's had practice of a
peasant's sandwich box now we had some
hot coffee and
and do not believe that it was
instructed by someone with a great deal
of thought for what its actual purpose
was it looks quite good but it's well we
keep Shelby safe we have not found
anything further other than many more
thousands of wildebeest and zebra and
we're now going to be driving probably I
would say until around ten o'clock we'll
get home we will do our best to try and
find some night time hunting action
that's going to be our plan you'll see
if we can't spot some lions on the hunt
there is something that was hunted and
indeed eaten sort of and you see it
there Fergus there it is everyone and
well you see so much just gets left sort
of uneaten art here now we only have 90
seconds left and I don't think that
that's a nice image for you to be
leaving us on so let us move on
I do apologize once again we will do I
mean Fergus and I haven't managed to
deliver one full show at all without
being nailed by the rain so we will
hopefully manage that sometime very soon
we will also be out pretty much I mean
you must watch out from Facebook we will
be doing any night hunts that we get
will broadcasters there and then early
tomorrow morning they'll be the same
sort of thing it won't be me and then
I'll be out again tomorrow afternoon and
evening so that's the plan for the week
and then of course we go to first end
Friday we're into rehearsals and then TV
show on Saturday so that's what our week
looks like from tomorrow
all right everyone that is going to be
it from us I know it seems like very
short time we've been talking to thank
you for being with us and thank you very
much for the juma t involved in the show
that leave in the Cinch yeah yeah I was
on camera in the tent today so well done
you know good stuff from you and Taylor
and Bayern thank you to all of you for
your questions and comments we will do
our level best to bring you something
more stable tomorrow until then have a
wonderful evening
afternoon morning wherever you happen to
be in the world
you
you